I want to go over the most common forms
of meditation how each of them work what
benefits each bring and also who each of
them are for the next form of meditation
on our list is meta meditation also
known as loving kindness meditation when
you practice meta meditation your goal
is to send love in several directions
you start off by visualizing and sending
love towards Yourself by repeating a
predetermined phrase like may I be happy
after a while you do the same thing to a
friend then to a stranger then to
someone you dislike and finally to the
universe as a whole what sort of
benefits does this form of meditation
bring will loving-kindness meditation is
well known for increasing empathy
towards other people it has also been
shown to reduce pain reduce negative
emotions and even help with PTSD who is
this form of meditation for
metameditation is good if you feel like
you have a lot of hate or anger within
you whether it's guided towards yourself
or other people follow us for more
helpful tips